okay
we'll open up the subcommittees
um
needless to say i'm a little light on my
republican side so
i i i'll if we get to a place where we
want to have a you know
a serious thing it needs to say we won't
we will not take up any votes at this
moment
but i think i think most of stuff you
know the way i've kind of visualized all
this i think we're we'll we should be
pretty well unified i think we should be
all right
so we'll see how far we go
until we get to maybe homeowners
association bills and then we maybe then
we'll hit the wall
okay uh start out with 15.95 relative to
establishing a statewide food truck
license
uh is there anybody here who cares about
this bill
yes right just wanted to see okay so
just want to let i want to know who's in
the room so normally when we do
subcommittees we would never do it this
way we we're much more closer and
personal and
have contact and but obviously
covet changes everything um
if i understand this bill correctly
the idea was that we're going to create
a statute that was going to supersede
local communities
and i just don't see how that can work
at all
and you would say well you know isn't it
terrible that you know couldn't you just
get one license and have it work
everywhere but at the end of the day
the 15 cities or the towns that care of
the most about it
are the ones that people are going to
want to have a truck park there
and as we say in retail it's all about
location location location
and
so at this point i think what
uh uh i'm i'm willing an interim study
just to simply
you know that we'll take it up in
september and just see
is there some way we can find
some streamlined methodology
for licensure but it you know for
licensing these things but at this point
so yes
i did talk with the prime sponsor on
this last night and um
he knows that there are a lot of issues
with it he brought it forward because
the constituent requested it right he's
um
i think he'd be okay within our study or
he would also offer an amendment to
put together a small sub uh study
committee to look at the issues they i
mean we've got one
coming up
an activity coming up
and they'd like to be able to have more
you know several food trucks
and that is one of the issues that when
somebody you know in some town that
wants to put together a
a fairly good size
um
activity that they like more than you
know a few
couple foods so when you talk about a
yeah i'm sorry can you come up and speak
with the mic and
sorry
and introduce yourself so everybody
knows who you are thank you
good morning for the record my name is
colleen smith i'm the administrator of
the food protection section within dhhs
so if it's a one day event they're
exempt from our license some of these
self-inspecting cities and towns do
license temporary one-day events but
if by law if they're operating four days
or less in a 30-day period or in
conjunction with a temporary event like
a fair festival that's not greater than
14 days they're exempt from our food
license well that's even better yeah
so that kind of takes care of that
problem huh yeah i think that it does
and i'll be glad to report back he was
unable to be here today okay so you'll
let him know that okay well maybe we
don't really need i mean the interim say
i was just thinking that we just keep it
around so we could talk about yes
yeah we have a bill coming up 1043 that
i think we should uh recommend
otp because it's establishing a
committee to study regulations
uh applicable to small business that
sell food and that would include uh push
carts i mean and uh food trucks push
carts we've got that one solved so
this one here uh
do we would rather have a i i i don't
really like study committees i would
rather keep it in in-house right don't
you think that somebody
why
i mean
aren't we going to be studying this
issue
what i'm saying if we okay if so which
one you're saying you think we should
1043. you think you should we should
pass 1043. yes and uh put the first and
second bill into 1043 and that would be
well we just yeah well we don't have to
because it's already in there right
isn't it already in 1043
i mean i don't know you have the
language of 10 43 pretty much
i have a question well that's something
we can decide which way my preference
would be to keep a bill if you had a
choice if i had a choice between a study
committee
or have it within the committee
i would rather keep it in the committee
because the study committee doesn't mean
we're going to get appointed to it who
knows who's going to get appointed to
that study committee so you're saying
that if we're going to
this is going to be interim study so
we're going to be doing that interim
study would be that is in my mind is
sometimes better than a study committee
so would we do interim study for the
first three
no i just want to interim study uh just
one of them i i would only inter study
uh
this this first one but let me let me
see let me see what the dude
okay okay i can also you if i don't make
sense i understand
i've been told that before but okay
okay state local rail including food
licensing food safety can i ask a
question of miss smith yes
um thank you um so would this apply
though to the towns that have their own
ordinances
the the temporary situation temporaries
yes
no many of them do license temporary
events
this would just that would just apply to
those operating in the state's
jurisdiction okay okay thanks very much
yes representative greeson
thank you and i don't know who the
question is for so if somebody can
provide an answer that would be awesome
uh
from my understanding from testimony is
there is a state license
that covers everything except for these
was it 15 cities that self license
then you have to go to each individual
city to get licensed in each of those
individual cities
so is there a way that we could have a
state license that allows you to operate
outside of those like a normal but then
a license that we can arrange with these
15 communities that they can that they
can get it's one license to allow them
to operate in those 15 it's a separate
license they would have to get that
allows them to get because we understand
that these licenses and the inspections
and all that has to do with revenue for
those cities and they inspect but if we
had one license that allows them that
they can purchase optionally it's like a
super mega license
so you can operate throughout the state
and then you buy the super plus and then
you can operate inside those cities as
well and then we could still figure out
the you know how to get inspected if
you're inspected in one city it's valid
in all the cities or whatever something
like that but that way
they can go to each individual city if
they want because that's where they're
going to be operating only
but if they want to be able to operate
or expand and franchise out they
wouldn't have to buy individual licenses
they could buy that one big super
license
the answer is no okay right and this
goes and this goes back to john hunt's
rule of licensure
why do we create licensure
this licensure is our methodology it's
our hammer
to shut you down when you've been bad
so that little
town that city
wants to be able to issue the license to
operate in that city
if to say is we don't we think we have a
problem with you we want to shut you
down
that city can't the only way you can
exert that authority is it has its own
licensure its own little baby
okay
to say that we're going to create a
state license how does that little city
going to shut down that business
if your license is actually a state
can't we work with them to figure out
a means again this would be the super
license that allows these people to
operate in those cities and we can get
them to agree that hey if this guy is
violating
then we have the ability some kind of
ability to to
nip that license if he's violating
something
but rather than going to 15 different
cities you're not going to 15 different
cities because you're never going to
operate in 15 different cities
no
okay you remember the food trucks that
used to go around
at lunchtime fleet of them yeah those
food trucks at lunchtime i know what
they call it
the roach coach absolutely okay
the roach coach never went beyond one
city i understand that okay what if he
wants 16 roach coaches what if this guy
is super entrepreneur
if that if there's a super entrepreneur
wants to say i'm going to do all these
different activities he has to he'll
probably identify which vehicle is going
to be
in that
city
and therefore get the license for that
the issue is we do have a super license
we have a super license as long as you
don't go
to these 15 communities where there's
money to be made
and and the logic is that each one of
those little and i know that you're
looking at the money okay
i'm looking at as the rule of licensure
i'm looking at as the whole the whole
reason they license them in the first
place is that if as soon as you
sell that use you know that salamilla
point you know poison they want to be
able to shut you down
right then and there and they don't want
to the sauerkraut that's really sour
that's how it's corrupted
i was thinking about that low main
that kid in massachusetts so so at any
rate uh so the answer is no you really
can't fill it okay
so this
this study committee i just read over
this study committee
in uh
this thing is all over the map
and and and it only has one person from
commerce
you know and that so it's really it's
like all these other committees are real
environment and agriculture they're all
the ones who are i don't know do you
really want to pass this i wouldn't want
to pass this
right
well i would i would
yeah so i would like to interim study
and then we'll kill 1095 and 1043 and
i'll tell you why in a moment
okay
okay so let's let's take the motion out
all right so
you want to know who's on the
subcommittee i i well i have here is
abel weston fargo and herbert
and you guys have a full house
here
uh i didn't have that one on here
yeah you do we have five
oh okay all right
so
so who who was that i mentioned that
it's not on here
osborne hamm
johnson
abel weston fargo herbert mcclear
abel weston
is here
representative ham is here three four
five
one two osborne's missing well this is
obviously wrong this list
i mean
there's no way i'm going to have five
democrats and four republicans i gave it
to you mr chairman
somebody got published somebody was on
and somebody might not have been paying
attention
i have a
is hunt osborne ham and johnson
four republicans yep and then has able
weston fargo and herbert
right meckler moved from insurance
to
business because of 1502 3 and 4. who
moved mclear moved from insurance to
business because of 1502 3 and 4.
okay
all right
i have a question he knows more about
does anybody have a problem with the
motion of uh interim study on this bill
can i ask why we wouldn't just itl this
because we have we want to have one
study committee to talk about this whole
licensure of vehicles
and and just have one vehicle
to talk about it okay
because i just see a lot of problems
with this bill it's just bad
it's not bad every bill has a grain of
truth to it i know what this does is it
costs the state
i mean it will cost more to do this than
we'll make in revenue and then you're
taking away revenue from the
municipalities
so i don't no we well i i let's the rule
of licensure does not include
worrying about fees
it's not about a money maker i and i
really i have to say to you i mean
all due respect for your party but we
republicans were are somewhat conscious
of the fact that
licensure should not be about a revenue
generating to the state of new hampshire
it should only the license should only
be to match the cost that it would take
us to implement that statute
that we used to have uh a rep av davis
who she was on
ways and means and she was the god of
licensure and she she would goddess and
licensure and she would make sure that
no fee was absorbent you know there was
never intended to be a revenue generator
right but we
but what if you look at the fiscal note
all i'm saying is it would cost
700 to hire a person
to manage this and we would only get
about 40 000 in revenue so that's what
i'm doing nothing else that's a good
reason to kill to not pass this bill
right
that's why i was suggesting itl but i
can do interim study i'm okay with that
okay good just
all right so uh representative ham is
here all right good
so uh
representative greeson is replacing
replacing osborne
just a lot shorter
okay and a lot and representative
johnson's not here okay so
uh and then oh but i have yeah i'll take
johnson so i have patoo okay
all right now we're in good shape who
would like to uh write the blurb for
this one
don't jump up if it wasn't okay
all right i will move uh interim study
seconded by representative patusek is
there any discussion on the motion of
as a subcommittee so what happens when
we get to the full committee
then we've already done the subcommittee
work whatever and and and to be honest
why i do it this way is that sometimes
someone will come in with an amendment
and i go well where were you when we had
our subcommittee with your amendment
so
that's my rationale of doing it this way
could you could you repeat the bills
that are going
into this so the net right now
this is just this bill we're doing is
15.95 okay
is interim study
okay so
and the next two i'm going to it out yes
okay
so you've got some subs for
your
your side
uh yes i'm all set
so all those in favor please raise your
hand
one two three i'm just gonna assume it's
eight people okay
so they can count it up for me
eat this up okay
all right one
down 24 to go okay
all right um
okay
10.95 a sale of fresh condiments and
pushcarts selling frankfurters and
pre-cooked sausages
a day or two after the hearing i had
this brilliant idea why wouldn't we
do like new york city and have a
uh
a push card plus
so that you could have all the perks and
everything as a push card plus
uh and then we did a little research and
found out that uh the new york city does
require that you have a restaurant
being affiliated in a facility so i went
through that going through all that
and finally i talked to uh
representative wild and and the sponsor
actually that yeah the the guy he his
constituent
and it came down to what he really
really wanted was the chili dog
that's what it was all about it was
about the chili dog
and so then this took me another
couple of hours i don't know how it took
me to figure this out and i said
well heck
we already allow
these push guard guys to have anything
that's in a single use packaging
and which evidently much to my amazement
that you can get sauerkraut in a single
use packaging
okay but you can get anything in a
single use packaging including
chili
and so i dually called up
the department and she said no problem
it's already in the rule
because it's a single used packaging we
don't have to do anything
all they have to do is have the cider on
you know on the that biscuit side of
these
the uh that have the
the chili
and you know maybe something else i
don't know maybe you can have baked
beans
you can have anything you want so
go ahead yeah i think what um what the
food car or the push carts um or the hot
dog stands what they need to do is
partner up with a commissary not that
they need to you know spend a lot of
money in the commissary or time but they
can um uh if if they want to have you
know their recipe or chili you know
produced in little packages they can go
to a commissary that's licensed by the
state and they can get it from there or
they can buy it from the grocery store
but if you work with a commissary then
you know the ingredients and you can you
know and it's not a big deal you know
they they can a commissary can you know
charge them
yeah the issue was that they really
don't want to do business with the
commissary
they don't want to do business because
the
the commission the local kid whatever
around them are going to treat them as
competitors
no well
okay
so that that was the the person who came
in who introduced the bill that was his
he was worried about in sunapee that he
was you know that but the commissary as
i now learned is a much more complicated
problem
and so it's not it's not easy
even just having the commentary because
it's still the whole point is their
kitchen is certified and registered and
yada yada yada and um but anyway so the
simple solution is as long as that cart
has everything in a single use packaging
they can go ahead and sell it to the
consumer there
representative herbert
but under existing law right now if
somebody hooks up with the commissary
they can do a sidewalk
food stand correct so that's legal
that's a little bit different you want
to do it that way yes okay
all the more reason to kill the bill
then
because you can already do that
okay yes representative mclaren but
my understanding that the the mustard
and the ketchup that he uses is in a
pre-manufactured package correct so
my understanding is that
this the hot dog guy can't make his own
chili and put it into a package correct
therefore it seems to me that some
entrepreneurial will make millions
pre-packaging uh chile
so i think if there's any entrepreneurs
out there they should
i guess i would look at the department
and say uh think of that uh
that somewhat problematic
because
um if i understand correctly if somebody
were just you know they if they had the
proper kitchen
to how they seal that package that would
actually
comply with the rule so that they could
you want to come over here said i'm
sorry
just stay there for until we get yeah
just you can sit here and we'll stay
here until we get through these three
bills
so so they if they could get licensed to
make those pre-packaged
chili cups or if they're hermetically
stealing them they would have to um you
know submit a plan and show that they're
packaging them safely but there there
would be a pathway for them to do that
so like a deli
so what's the deli there and jackson
there the uh the only one that stays
open for lunch
the jackson tele so
so they would have to still submit a
plan that they were going to be selling
these to a third party yes
okay because otherwise they can sell
them now they can you know put it in the
refrigerator and sell it now a deli can
do that now yes right but in terms of
selling it to a third party would they
have to
go through jump some hoops to do that if
they were going to give it to a cart as
long as they have a it depends on again
how they're packaging if they're
packaging it to be shelf stable then um
we would definitely want to look at
their process because they'd have to it
have to go under sealed has to be sealed
exactly
so but if it was just
they they could do a deli could do it
they have seven days for the customer to
use it without any kind of additional uh
like thermal processing okay
okay so
representative bartlett um thanks mr
chair so in the blurb that if it goes
into the consent calendar um it would be
important for the person that writes
this to just kind of say
there are rules in place for this they
can be covered so the constituent
understands that it was really
not going against what he was asking
no i i i actually talked to him oh you
did okay great so
you know but since you mentioned that
representative bartlett seconded by
representative 26 moves
idl
represented able
okay
and uh seconded
by representative
patusek
okay for in uh for itl
okay all those in favor please say aye
those opposed
moved unanimously to zero
okay
all right
all right now last but not least
uh establishing a committee to study
regulations applicable to small
businesses that sell food
um i feel like i've learned enough
just in the last couple of weeks that i
ever wanted to know about food and i'm
okay for the moment and uh is there
anybody else that thinks
we should keep this bill alive
okay perfect
so who would like to make a motion
represent herbert perfect
say bye represent hunt
yeah
ito
okay all those in favor say aye
those opposed so moved unanimously okay
i think now we're all set
thank you very much
okay
mr chair can you back up to 1595 who's
doing the blurb on that
uh
i haven't let's see what did i i the
motion was
1595. the motion was made by me oh
you're doing it okay so
okay i'm just tracking
yeah
but if you like to make the motion when
we take it out for the full committee
that's it's okay too
actually i might do that
okay
i will make that
1503 uh they went through its final
review
and uh they found eight uh references
that still needed to be corrected and
readjusted um so hopefully that'll be uh
uh
available sometime today so at this
point um we're not gonna take up 1503 at
this moment we'll we'll wait
now here's the deal on 1503 it is a
hundred page bill
so uh once we once it's available we
will be
making it available as a pdf for anybody
and everybody who really wants to read
it and go into it and get into detail
yes representative
correct
okay
yeah no that's fine
but once we get it we'll get the we have
to get the new hampshire version of it
so that that should be available today
so at this point we're not going to take
up because we it's not we don't have it
we don't have it
i'd be interested to hear what your what
your interest is
but in this document you can knowingly
accept
um
stolen
bitcoin type of cyber crypto currencies
and there's no repercussions from the
person who buys them and i think that's
a real issue
okay
so we will we will make sure that once
we get the new hampshire version you can
see whether that's still in there or
whether they it's interpreted
differently
what amendment is that
okay so my amendment was we would call
it um
ucc light
which basically did nothing other than
say this is what a ucc would look like
so
[Laughter]
okay
so no that's why that that that was that
was the first um
if if we had to have this bill out
before you know what you know early okay
which was actually it wasn't 1503 i
think it was 1502
with which we had to get out early so
the 1503
because that one was um did not have a
fiscal note to it
that was the one that we just that we
would then be able to dodge that bullet
to having to take action right away with
the original 1502
the
once issue get a little closer to the
mic so everybody at home can hear you
even have it on um the other issue when
we were discussing this in the beginning
is that our this was running into um
problems with the with the sec right
no
this is not the sec problem okay all
right i'll leave that alone then
all right thank you yes represent
michael did i understand that we're
putting all of this on the table
awaiting the governor's study
that's what i thought
well i have no idea where you got that
idea all right
the governor's study is out of left
field and nobody asked me about it
it's not
just as an aside did anybody hear the
article this morning on npr yes i did
yes it was very interesting and i would
suggest that everybody on the committee
pull that up um on npr well it's about
the problems that china's had because
china trying to decide they they
couldn't control it three years ago when
we were here discussing a bill very
similar to this um you know one of the
arguments was well if we don't do
something about it china's going to come
in because they're doing so much right
now they're out of it completely for a
lot of good reasons
no i didn't say there was a lot of good
reasons oh well i have to disagree i
tried to listen to that new story
completely really i would really suggest
that everybody listen to that article
and he said it took too much electricity
it's probably you know at least 10 or 15
minutes long
so but here's my take on this that
actually what was interesting was the
fact that um
where their their setup is in nebraska
okay
and i have no idea what nebraska has
done
but i do know one thing about nebraska
is that there are unicamery legislature
and so they they don't have a feature
that we have here in new hampshire
and that is that
if we were to pass this bill
and send it over to the senate
that there will be a whole new set of
eyes a whole new pause
to really go through it and really make
sure
that this thing is safe and and that yes
it is true the senate might punt and
just say we'll wait for the governor's
commission
okay
or
they might hear that everyone thinks
this is the cat's meow
and
let's let's go for it
and send it to the governor so and i
would say that that the one advantage we
do have is we are a bicameral
legislation and so yes there will be
plenty of chances to to
get go through this piece of legislation
yes
banking um credit unions i mean how do
they feel about this bill
they uh all are okay they are all with
us concept of the ucc yes they think
this is a great idea and here's the
reason why they think it's a great idea
the most offensive bill was 1504
which was the creation of a whole new
division in the bank department
that was
that was the worst possible scenario
you could imagine
creating
50 by doing 1503 as a ucc simply a ucc
statute not only the the department that
we have that oversees it okay the
securities had immediately come in with
the appropriate language
to address their issues
but
in their uh over in the secretary of
state's office we have our our guru our
ucc guru
who has been working on this so this is
all done within the state agencies in
terms of making this ucc thing work
and and frankly uh if if in any moment
any banks or credit unions or anybody
come in and say no this is not a good
idea i would have you know
i would have shut the whole thing down
but at this point everybody is very
excited about us
going forward with this
and i certainly hope you will find that
true too
representative weston yes thank you um
i i think that that
the difference here is by the way
pakistan and india are also
on the move to ban
this industry completely so it's not
just china it's some of the major
industrial countries
i think that the banks and the big
financial firms are interested in seeing
how they can make money off it
they're not going to put themselves at
risk they just want to be able to make
money off it which is why they're not
opposed to it
but i think we need to
really watch this industry very
carefully because it's
it's a dangerous industry it's full of
fraud
well here's my concern just to address
that issue right now
right now and this is herbert ii
is
i didn't i'm not sure i
i i bought some mead from from our you
know my meetery and he and then somehow
i ended up i got a 40 discount if i sign
up with paypal
credit card evidently i now have a
paypal credit card not that they sent me
a card but i got it
but then so then i'm now going to go
online to pay my bill
and right there in paypal
they're taking crypto
they're taking it this is it's out there
it's out there is exchanging is doing it
so shouldn't we make sure
that uh
if
this is out there
and i'm i assume paypal is a fine
upstanding entity and not a money
launderer
[Music]
they they aren't going to invest in it
they're just going to make money off it
here's the point
what banks in terms of like as those of
us who have trust
okay that so those of us have trust yeah
did there some of us would want and some
of them have trust issues
that they would we would want to maybe
put it in our portfolio and have our
portfolio managers keeping an eye on and
tracking and reporting on it for us
okay so i understand
it's a little scary it's no no i'm not
running out to buy it but i don't do
gold either
okay you know
but at the same time it's out there and
why wouldn't it make sense for the state
of new hampshire
to at least um you know create take what
is going to become law
in every state in the next four or five
years but gambling is out there too and
some of us gamble and some don't
yeah we're making lots of money off of
that now right from
in the super bowl then when they find
25 percent of our betters were from
massachusetts
but there's another issue here we do not
necessarily need to be first in the
nation here i mean there are places
where new hampshire wants to be first in
the nation but i think this is such a
a delicate thing here it's very
i just don't think this is where we want
to put out the welcome mat
and the business with the trust i mean
when the pandora papers were stolen who
was sighted in there new hampshire is
one of the places where oligarchs can
come and hide their tainted money
i just don't think this is where new
hampshire wants to be okay well you're
entitled to your opinion and
i'm sure your constituents would think
you're absolutely right new hampshire
should
stay in the hinderlands on this on this
issue representative herbert
um a question i have is
if the federal government sup does the
federal government have the ability to
supersede the ucc
if they find it to be
something that they don't want to deal
with
the federal government would always have
the authority to supersede anything any
state does
absolutely okay so okay but that's you
just understand the nature of ucc
is that and the reason why this is
number 12.
okay
if you go back and look at all the old
ucc you know the statutes
there's there is as old as our
rsas
okay and the reason being was that the
federal government had made the decision
that they weren't going to
create all the one super federal law
they were going to leave it up to each
individual state to have model
legislation in which every state had the
similar statute
i'm not i'm not this
further
would you believe i'm not questioning
the previous ucc
uh uh decisions right um what i am
questioning is that this particular area
is uh
should be a federal matter at minimum
and and i'm i'm positive that that's
where it's going to end up and uh
and so therefore
um
i'm i you know my point of view anyway
yes do you think it's money current
money not a banking issue
and uh and
as a result the banks may be able to
make a commission on
getting their fingers in in this uh pie
but uh
uh we we i have a currency issue problem
and so therefore it's i find it very
problematic fair enough okay yes
representative griezmann oh i have a
question thank you
is the objection
the fact that this is a digital
property
because if if the if the objection is
that it's i hear concerns about fraud
and money laundering well that's been
going on long before we ever had a
personal computer
but if the objection is that it is
digital
the federal reserve is already working
to establish a a digital dollar a
digital currency
so if you're worried about digital
take it up with the fed because it's
coming
so i'm not sure i understand what excuse
me
i understand but i'm saying that the
paper dollar is going to go away and
it's going to be all digital
so so
is that this rumor has the federal
government was playing with the digital
concept but they haven't they're not
actually stated they're working on it
i
what i read is that it ain't happening
okay
on the other side of the coin is just
remember
there are multiple companies in this
industry
bitcoin is not
is it's just it's it's their competitors
so it's a free marketplace on the these
choices of products are out there
so
it is not a currency it's a commodity it
is and and i would have to tell you that
one of the things when and and when i
spent many hours when they had the
original subcommittee the banking
department always took the position that
it was not currency
that it was a commodity and she called
them
beanie babies
okay
anybody else
yes yes yes
i don't
i don't think we care that it's digital
i mean i think that
what bothers me is exempting it from
security laws
no no
what is the need to exempt them from
security laws i mean
yeah
okay so you were right it's only 20
pages
so can anyone answer my question
it's not as it's not a security
it's property
that's your opinion exactly that's your
opinion
correct
yeah the sec has ruled it is not a
security it's not traded as a security
it's treated as property
it's a commodity
okay so um
it everybody has a copy of it
and you can use it as
on your snow day reading
and hopefully it will make you go to
sleep early and we'll be taking this up
next week
okay
but i i would i sure hope i mean i i
hear your concerns and i hope you guys
will
uh use the resources you have and the
people you know
to communicate and people you trust
uh to find out whether you know you this
is something you want to get behind but
um i i
i would not i'd say myself personally i
would not be pushing this if i did not
think this was a good thing for new
hampshire
and it's not you know as you know i'm
not that partisan
and and so i i really do think that this
was a great solution
um in terms of how the role we play um
and like i say i was around when we
basically decided that we were going to
have no statutes no law
regulating this and leaving it up to the
attorney general's office for someone
just you know to use you know the right
or pride of action and suing and just
the fact that that
this is the industry is matured enough
to get to this point i think we don't
doubt your sincerity mr chair it doesn't
mean we'll necessarily agree with you
but we don't doubt your sincerity okay
so i just hope you you know check in and
talk to people about it because i think
you'll find there we are talking don't
worry good moving thank you uh
in in reference to the concern about um
penalties for receiving stolen property
i think it's a valid concern
but does the ucc
i i have no idea well i don't know
what's in here
we'll read it we'll read it and find out
do they normally would they normally
address that issue
is that something that would have been
addressed in chapters 1 through 11 that
have been adopted previously
or would that be something i
i cannot say i cannot say okay
okay uh all right moving along
in
1146 relative to condominium instruments
and kind of mean special assessments
okay
agrees
uh right so what do we have here
so johnson's here ham's here
uh petusek will replace osborne
and
abel herbert fargo weston
okay
all right so who
who would like to make the motion
okay representative
yeah i move that we i tail this
okay
um all those in favor of the motion say
aye
those opposed
zip
okay
well we don't need it yet so who
who was not when we had abel herbert
fargo and weston
who was not here originally was there
somebody that came here was not original
he was on
insurance but he moved over because of
and who was removed off of it
no there had to be somebody i would not
remove somebody over without replacing
somebody else
everybody wanted to be honest okay well
here's the bad news
okay
okay so representative patusek is
replacing osborne
and
i am adding for
this
next subcommittee i am adding greecen
and that is a
on this on on business and that is a
chairman's prerogative
yeah we're talking about the
because i want to get through all of
this you know
[Laughter]
okay
all right so so does that so is greason
off of insurance
no he's just on here right now
right now
so these two homeowners bill because i i
don't think i would ever have created
this list of
i mean i've always would have had a
republican majority including you know
so
at any rate
um
god
in all due respect
at the end of the day
for us to
tell condos
that they have to accept something they
don't want to accept
is just an anathema to me i just can't i
can't i just can't get my arms around
forcing them and i realize you want
solar and you really want to have solar
and solar is you know
if nothing else we would
we would love to see pvs on every
every house
in new hampshire
because then we would be generating
electricity you know and and good
electricity not
nuclear or or gas generated electricity
to run our electric cars that we're all
going to have okay
so there's no doubt in my mind i you
know i i am you know as someone who owns
you know
kilowatts of you know
pvs you know i'm i'm absolutely with you
but at the end of the day the problem of
these homeowners association condos you
know whatever
is that you know when you buy into it
you're buying into that that everybody
there is going to be on the same page
with you
and if you got a homeowner's association
where there's some stick in the muds who
say no i don't want your house to have
pvs
you know i want everybody's house to
look the same
all right then you you've sold your soul
to that
socialist government if i was to say
that okay
but you know that but obviously you know
you you're you still have the right to
ability to convince everybody in your
community that it'd be okay
but if if there are stick in the months
who don't want it
how do we how how
is that really right for the state to
force it on them
may i just yes
first of all this is enabling this is
not it's not a mandate uh as a matter of
fact it's the reverse of a mandate it
allows the freedom
of being able to put solar onto your
the mandate being that the association
could
say refuse
that's a mandate to me that you're
telling the association that if somebody
wants to put this on the roof they have
to accept it
is that not mandated no because this is
only enabling legislation so you have
ordinances and other layers on top of
this we're talking about the state level
here but um what i'm saying about is not
being a mandate is that it's allowing
freedom of the individual to have a
choice
not requiring the
the individual individual to do anything
so it's not a mandate in that sense so i
just want to clarify terminology off off
the topic yeah but i disagree with you
totally that's okay we've
disagreed you're saying it's
individual
this is an individual who lives in a
community yes and they want to force
their community
to do something when they okay that the
community could have
voluntarily agreed with them
and let them do it
but the community didn't and that's the
reason why you have this legislation in
front of us right and the issues that
the the constituents to whom i've spoken
and i've spoken to very many because of
where i live where i live is fraught
with uh condos and and homeowners
associations uh the issues that they
have there are two-fold uh one many of
these documents were crafted and as we
heard crafted decades ago
the the utility of of solar has grown
the cost-effectiveness of solar has
grown the interest in solar has grown
and so they these people are saying that
the documents while they did exist and
they were
important at that time are worth taking
a look at now so that's one of the
issues that i'm hearing about this the
other is that
they are hoping that the state will look
at the idea that
aesthetics should not be trumped
when it comes to the opportunity for
a fiscal economy for the chance for
clean energy
so
there's these people are saying that
things are different now
and that we have many people as you said
who are very fixated in this who are
saying okay it's a contract it's it's
something i have to abide by when we can
change contracts and that's what they're
asking for but again it's enabling it's
not a guarantee
so if this bill goes forward of the city
of manchester for instance has
ordinances and things that will make a
difference here to our to our
constituents
so those are the primary points here
there are many people who care about
this
right now they have a two-thirds bar
to get permission and their homeowners
associations to make this happen
uh many homeowners associations include
renters and people that that own blocks
of homeowners of homeowners uh units
and therefore the two-thirds hurdle is
very difficult to to uh
to reach also the snowbirds
who don't particularly care about having
that kind of interest whatsoever so
there are there are distinct reasons
here why the individual is looking for
an individual right that has not been
accorded because the documents came so
far back in the past the documents
are
worth taking a look at now and that's
what we're doing with this bill
okay representative mclaren
well it would seem to me whether we had
this bill or not that somebody in a
condo association could go to the
association and simply say let's amend
the agreement let's get to modern times
and this law would have no effect on no
need for this law
no need for this law
but the bar is two-thirds no it well
if everybody everybody in the community
thinks it's a great idea
you know there is no bar
there's no bar that everybody's agreed
yes let's do it and we've heard
testimony that people don't attend the
annual meetings that they don't that
they don't vote this just opens the door
for people to to do something on
property that they own now this is not a
condo
we had some concerns about condo versus
homeowners association this is not a
condo
if if the homeowners association owner
wishes to have something on his roof
it's it's his ownership he owns that he
owns the lot as well he or she i should
be
careful with my pronouns here but he or
she owns that lot and that roof
and now there are the things were
different in the last 30 or 40 years
since those documents were
were crafted so the the premise here and
again obviously if it's not not
something that we're ready to do
do here as a state
i think it will be something we'll be
ready to do in the very near future to
allow these things i mean i drove by the
gas pump on the way here i paid my
my heating bill
there are very valid reasons why
allowing our citizens the option for
more more cost-effective heat and for
more cost-effective energy should be on
the table and they should see that
rationalize it representative abel's
next and then represent fargo and then
representative herbert
thank you thank you mr chair
i was going to make the same point
as
was just made that this is only
referring to
homeowners associations not condos and
that there is there's a quite a bit of
legal difference between the two
a homeowners association
the owner owns the property
and owns the
owns the building
um
and
that there's no universal
uh two-thirds half of the members have
to agree to this
there's a lot of difference among
the bylaws and the deed restrictions for
for a homeowners association
and
i believe that this is this is a
forward-looking thing um
and that in fact
many people who live in homeowners
associations rue the fact that when the
buildings when the houses were
originally built
that the
builder didn't make them all
be solar powered
and
so
whether whether we want to act on this
or not i think is is
is a useful debate
but i don't see any anything in here
that would would change any would change
anything i i would
i can't see where
uh there why there's any reason not to
not to support you if the homeowners
association has written in their
agreement that everybody bought who
bought it signed
and agreed to
says there would be no exterior changes
to your
house
without permission from the homeowners
association
you don't see this bill basically
trumping
that deed restriction
i'd have to think about that and that
was crafted many decades ago
i've never seen to be frankly with you i
have never seen a homeowners association
agreement that doesn't have deed
restrictions oh absolutely i agree yeah
okay
and all we're saying here is
that
if it had any deed restriction that
would somehow
stop somebody from putting pvs
we're saying is
rip that out of that deed
and it just it just turns it back to the
locality
representative herbert
that's that's the question i have um
uh
i'm i thought i heard the sponsor say
that
some of these documents are are so
outdated
that i kind of got the impression that
they said you had to use gas or you had
to use
some particular type of
energy in order to
heat your
home
is that the case in some of these pardon
me we're just talking about external
fixtures really here
rather than
the heating system so it is not the case
that
some of the documents would uh prohibit
solar
um as
the chair said documents differ
it could have been to association so
there could have been an association
that specifically says
um
i'll give you a frank now i did my
homeowners association in 1982.
so i don't know if that's considered old
or young
but in my our original agreement we
wrote into it that everyone was supposed
to
not use fossil fuels as a primary
heating system
and that the houses should all be just
supposed to be solar homes
that's what i wrote way back then i was
young i was in my 20s
by the time i got to my 30s the
homeowners association decided they this
was problematic
and they did remove the exclude that
they could not use fossil fuels as
exclusive
but they made the choice they didn't
want oil trucks
so they said that you could use
natural gas propane as your
primary heating system that was and we
uniformly 100 percent
we didn't have to worry about the 230 we
uniformly agreed to that homeowner's
change
representative greason
thank you mr chair
if the state has established that
two-thirds
is what a homeowners association
majority must be
then could the state say to each
homeowners association we truly want to
make this enabling could we go out to
the homeowners associations and say you
can establish your own majority as long
as it's not doesn't exceed two-thirds
and then you can make whatever
that way
any homeowners association can do
whatever they want
with whatever majority they decide to
establish they just have to tell the
state what that majority is going to be
so if there's any questions
the state now knows hey you said it had
to be 60 you said it had to be 51 you
said it had to be whatever and they
could be held to that standard but if we
want to make it enabling
then say if you want to change your
standard on what a majority is you can
do that but we're not going to tell you
what you have to do
that's an interesting concept i would
just point out that we just voted down
the previous bill is to change the uh of
the home the association's
voting authority to approve a budget and
say we want to keep the current law in
its current form so i would be a little
careful with that i would say that um
many many many moons ago and i don't
think there's i don't know how many
people in the room were around when i
was around this actually was a hot issue
up in brenton woods when the developer
and there is you could have you had 10
years to develop out the houses and it
didn't get developed and the homeowners
association wouldn't refuse to give him
permission to fill up fill out the
development and it was a and and back
then
back then
the
attorney general's office
said in no uncertain terms
that the state should not be
getting involved indeed you know these
arguments should not be involved in this
at all that these are absolute property
rights now you all hear about how
sometimes when there's property needs to
be done and you've got to go find
distant cousins or any relative anybody
who could have had some connection that
it and that was a hundred percent there
was no 80. and we lowered it to 80 we
end up doing it to 80 we end up lowering
the number but i'm just saying that this
is a very sensitive issue because people
who sign that deed
expect deed restrictions to be held up
by law
representative weston yeah thank you um
i think that a lot of the testimony was
about the visual aspect of having solar
panels on the houses and i understand
that that a lot of people don't like the
way they look
but uh shingles are being developed now
that have
the that same capability and i think the
whole
argument is going to change considerably
as soon as we have those shingles
available
they'll look just like any other roof
yeah hopefully i've always wondered
about you know the steel roofs
and why we can't somehow when that sun
is out and hitting that steel and it's
really warming up that steel that we
can't capture that energy somehow and
i've always wondered who somebody should
be working on that technology
yes yes
yes
just one last point um
the last constituent to whom i spoke
about this
is in favor and brought up the point
that the last thing that she would want
to do
is to deny her neighbor the opportunity
to save money and to have clean energy
for how something looks
and she reported to me that there was a
an ungodly piece of artwork that is on
the porch
of the neighbor next door
and
the issue of aesthetics really is not as
strong as the issue of
healthy clean living and clean air and
clean heat and so her point is i will
live with the ungodly artwork next door
but i will really want to make sure that
that person who wants to have better
heating and better energy has that
opportunity to do so so just just to
clarify
the kinds of input that i've been
getting and by the way i am not in a
homeowner's association there has not
been clarity about that uh i live in a
condo association
and i cannot have solar energy i would
love to have it but that's not an option
to me because of the structure that i've
chosen to live in the building can't
really handle it
so represent him
thank you for taking my question
i feel
fairly strongly on both sides of this
issue um
knowing a bit about it and understanding
both points of view
there is a public interest here to
encourage
homeowners to take advantage of
things that have a public good or a
public benefit
there are
associations that have been around a
long time
and perhaps the state of the art
was different when they were formed
and why uh to require
uh folks that are building new in in the
development another phase of it need to
um stick with a standard that was uh the
standard uh in in 1980 or or 2010 with
with all the standards changing so
so uh quickly and dramatically
uh in construction in
heating sources and and and
all the basic
uh aspects of building
i just wondered if we have another
choice
to do with this bill something else we
can do with this bill not kill it not
pass it
because i think myself i feel
about equally strongly on both sides of
this issue wanting to maintain that's
why you buy into an association
you want to guarantee that the community
is going to look
pretty much as you
chose to buy into
versus
the opportunity to take advantage of
changes in technology and changes in
standards over time and not be
stuck
building a
chalet style
or
or putting in
a type of energy source that is no
longer
in vogue so i feel strongly this still
does not address any new
projects going forward but
and i would i would say i would venture
to say i would be very surprised of
anybody who was going forward with a a
new homeowners association
wouldn't actually want to have pvs and
wouldn't be urging people to do it
because i'm sure the contractor would
love
to
charge that extra onto that building and
putting it up so i can't imagine going
forward any new project this is only for
ones that are already built and fully
built out and fully built up any empty
lots
like i said empty lots would be the
developer can when he sells the deed
he can then write whatever he wants in
in that deed and certainly i'm sure they
would make permission for photovoltaics
um well further in that case they know
what they're buying they know exactly
what they're buying correct exactly what
the community looks like exactly what
what they're getting and what they're
agreeing to
so you okay with killing this bill um
if that is the case then it only applies
to existing situations and you know
exactly that you're buying
um something that's
does not have pvs and doesn't allow it
because the because there's some stick
in the muds in that community won't
change the rules and they have the
opportunity to go to their um
association meeting exactly
in that case if it if it if it does not
cover anybody
uh um they know what they're getting
they know what they're buying they're
not buying a lot and uh
having to
be in unable to take advantage of new
technology then i guess
i would say
i tell it okay great
representative johnson seconds by
representing him moves in extreme to
legislate
any discussion representative bartlett
thank you mr chair i'm i'm sort of in
the same position that representative
hamm is in
we built a homeowner's association in 92
um here in in concord up at mountain
green and
it was 25 a year to put flowers by the
front entrance that was really the only
thing we contributed to
i remember that we weren't allowed to
hang clothes where anybody could see
them
well
we have our dryer is manufactured in
1968. i've never used it my kids used to
come home from college and use it so we
always hang our clothes but they weren't
where anybody could see them
um
we moved
after the kids left we need a big house
so we um built up um up the road a bit
and then a new con new homeowners
association went in
on sanborn road very nice association
that was really different though
they only own even though they have
beautiful homes and they start around
they only own six feet out from the
foundation the rest of it is common area
where the other homeowners association
you know we had
between three quarters and two acres per
lot right um so i started so when this
bill came up i had to start thinking
about what that difference was
i would like to see this
interim study
i really think
that there are different kinds of
homeowners associations out there with
different
ideas of how
how solar could be incorporated
and
as we heard just yesterday
the under reporting and underestimating
by our government of where we are
um regard of all governments just not
our government but all governments of
where we are as far as how we reduce our
our
reliance on fossil fuel is is
much lower than what it really is
um
than what's being reported
we have got to make some difficult
decisions about how we reduce
our reliance on fossil fuel and that
means everybody so i would like to see
those of us that are
on the fence about this
consider an interim study motion
i mean and what are you going to get
with an interim study i mean at the end
of the day
it's the question is are you going to
force homeowners associations except
something
that evidently some members of that
homeowner association don't want to
accept
that's
to me that's the policy to build forget
about the solar i mean they could be
something even
even better than solar out there okay
that we would all sit there and say why
what is wrong with that person that they
doesn't want to agree to that the idea
that this committee could vote as
interim study as a recommendation means
that the
subject can continue to be discussed and
i think that's a different message than
just killing it and saying nope we're
not going to do anything
and that's why we have interim study as
an option
and so i would like to see us be able to
consider that
yes connie i i just like to respond to
what you said and i do understand your
point of view i understand all the
points of view because
this is a complex issue uh even though
it
at its heart and soul
it isn't
you're looking at it from the point of
view that we are forcing the
associations to accept something that
they don't want
and my constituents are asking me to
come to you and say
we'd like to have you look at the rights
of the individual
the the individual homeowner who's paid
the mortgage who's paid the the bills
who owns the building
to look at those rights instead so just
to give you the other side of the
viewpoint
so
what you really want us is to
urge
new future homeowners associations
to consider allowing solar
well that's true that's not the spell
but
i think christie's viewpoint is well i'm
trying to spin this how we're going to
rationalize why we would keep this bill
alive we're that somehow to urge
homeowners associations to be nice to
their neighbors and do something for
them and and let them you know save
energy and that that how how could that
be for the greater good of all of us
if they just put pvp and i know that
interim study is a is a gentle kill yeah
generally okay we're a second year i
mean let's get real about this a second
but i still think we can send a message
you know as a committee that says okay
it is a complex issue
it is worth
continuing a discussion
and that
we in commerce do feel that
solar voltaic cells are something that's
happening in the future hopefully i get
mine in the next three weeks
so how do the
republicans feel about that mr speaker
as a former nuclear reactor operator
i am very much in support of nuclear
energy
oh should we talk everybody should have
a nuclear fusion
i i
i started working on a pigeon several
years ago
how each individual home could have its
own little reactor to generate
centuries worth of
free electricity and i'm not joking
okay so um
nuclear i'm very much in support of
nuclear energy and we need to pursue
that
every bit as much as we pursue anything
else
representation thank you mr chair
i look at the
homeowners association as a private
business
pub pub semi-private business owned by a
group of stockholders who are the
homeowners and is not the job of this
committee to mandate anything to a
private business
in this way thank you mr chair okay
motion is inexpensive to legislate and i
think we've discussed this enough um all
those in favor of uh anything to
legislate raise your hands
one two three
four five
and those opposed oh wait excuse me
oh sorry
just
uh okay
and all all opposed
two
three
how many
i got herbert
abel
yeah fargo you're
yeah and fire goes on
okay
because it because how many numbers that
i came out i have one two three four
five six seven eight nine
right so it's seven to two
so what somebody you couldn't vote
no
okay
all right
we're done with that
john may i just say that i do appreciate
the um the input and the and the the
good dialogue that we had here
obviously it didn't go in the direction
that i wanted from my constituents and
uh but i think we are putting us back on
the radar and thinking about it and
that's part of what we do here so thank
you very much okay good i'm glad you
feel like you got a fair hearing and
then
so good
okay uh next up 1378.
um
that was standing in the the fundamental
issue of
you know having getting a warrant for
this and then the the sponsor came up
with this amendment that had some
uh
there was some limitations of when the
warrant whatever was necessary
um
i guess i couldn't get beyond the
language of the the actual law that just
needs to be fixed
and so i my preference would be to
interim study this bill so that at least
can get clean up the statute
and and see if there were some
parameters that
you know requiring a warrant was was
appropriate or not
um but at this point i'm not
overly excited about taking that issue
on
and how does everybody else feel i agree
the only concern i had was making sure
that
going for i agree with with interim
studying this and because of the
age of this
of the current statute uh it needs an
overhaul need to totally work going
forward there does need to be
some statement
to the effect of a warrant would be
necessary to compel compliance i totally
agree with the idea of
law enforcement and the innkeeper would
have the ability to comply at their will
but when you talk about
compelling compliance
you need a warrant
yeah i guess yeah i mean
being in the vacation rental business i
don't even know where i would begin
because we have no idea who's in the
house
you know we don't i know there's some
vacations i know where one time we
rented a property
and um
i think it was in colorado and they and
they expected us to tell every name of
every person that's in the house
and
frankly i really didn't i think they
were their
goddamn business
knowing what my grandchildren's names
were
you know like is how offensive that was
that i'm supposed to let them know who's
who's there and you know you all you
need is one name the o the person who
was renting
i i could understand any adult the names
of any adults
that are going to be on the property
having that information um
yes i don't i to me this brought up so
many cans of worms that i it's it's
really awkward in terms of that
enforcement ability issue you know i
mean i grant you that if
you know
in my case
if a
law enforcement showed up at the house
and said i want to know who's renting
just
well it's the only people there is the
wretches right
and that's when you can say that's none
of your business
why do you want to know i mean if they
come in and say is john doe staying here
if as a law abiding citizen interested
in in law enforcement trying to catch
the bad guys which we all want you could
say oh yes sir i have a john doe named
here or that's listed as staying here
and then is he nobody's i'm not even
there
i'm i'm i could be out of state i could
be down in my summer home in rhode
island when they show up to the house in
new hampshire
and say i mean this is not anybody paid
enough attention to what's going on i
know i know up in jackson there's a lot
of people watching reading about it
because it was in the newspapers on the
conway paper here almost every day
about
these rentals but you know the issue is
whoever owns the property
that is renting it out
should have
should know who's staying there if you
don't know who's staying there then
oh my goodness somebody tears up your
place how do you hold them accountable i
have i have a 775 deposit well that may
not cover much of anything
but my point is
is we're looking at this this is totally
from a law enforcement standpoint
okay
you should know who's staying on your
property if you don't care well that's
your business uh kind of reckless to me
but i want to know who's staying in my
home
any adults that come in and stay in my
home i want to know who they are
so having that information
is is my purview
now if the law enforcement comes along
and says mr greeson
who is staying in your home
i have the right to say none of your
business
but i also have the right to say
well who are you looking for and why
and if i feel like i want to answer the
question
i can answer the question if they say
specific names i can say yes or no but
to compel my compliance you better have
a warrant if you want to come and search
the property you better have a warrant
so you know we're looking they're not
searching the property they're just
they're just wanna they want to see
if the name they're a person they're
looking for
is registered and ready and anybody
who's who's not a trying to harbor
criminals is going to be like yeah this
guy's staying here go get him get him
off my property
you know
so so i i i'm just saying that having a
list of names is not an unreasonable
thing
but you don't have to you don't have to
give that to anybody
right
unless they have a warrant in which that
compels you to comply
okay
yeah i hear you i i think that the
warrant is going to be a problem but
i think at least we need to rewrite the
statute and let's see how we can
get there but
um
i don't know i i the warrant might be
problematic
but but anyways
let's see what let's see when we just
study what the study come up he comes up
with
okay yes
rich
yes thanks um
i thought that
when we had the hearing
representatives of law enforcement made
a very good
case for
for why this is helpful to them and i
didn't completely understand
uh the proponents
of this bill and
i thought that was a weaker presentation
but it also seems to me that that
this really ought to go to to uh
public safety i wish we could just refer
to them and let them figure it out a
different yeah um but i guess we can't
do that so we have to we have to we have
to we
can't we can't okay all right so it's
it's our responsibility all right so i i
i think i think it actually should be
itled
but that's my opinion
represent bartlett i feel the same way i
mean i can support the interim study but
i just soon see it killed
yeah i i
to me that we got to clean up the
statute i can't let it let that sit
there like that you know
so representative fargo
um
i i think there were two things that
concerned me uh when we were we were
hearing from the law enforcement people
um
because it takes eight to 48 hours to
get a warrant which could impede their
ability to prevent a crime but it also
if they needed to identify victims in
the case of
you know um
something happening um
that that would be a problem as well so
i think the bill is it stands as pretty
flawed i'd like to i agree that probably
this
the statute or whatever should be
rewritten but this particular bill i i
i would like to see it in expedient to
legislate
okay
there are there are such things as
exigent circumstances and probable cause
things that law enforcement officers
understand
as to when and how they can enter
property and what things they can and
cannot do again if it if it's a matter
that's a completely different matter if
there's a crime in progress or if a
criminal has left the scene and entered
it that that that that establishment
that's completely different from going
in
and saying is john doe staying here
and that's the way this was presented
and so do you have a list of the of the
of the occupants of this establishment
and the innkeeper
can
say
no or yes or i don't have to answer
what we're getting down to is compelling
compliance
and it has nothing to do with leave it
up to the innkeeper to decide what's
that leave it up to the innkeeper to
decide
well the innkeeper can say can answer
questions or they can refuse to answer
questions but in order to compel
compliance
you need the warrant
yeah we i watched uh french kiss uh
this weekend
one of my wife's favorite movies with
nick ryan and and the and the and the
concierge said i um
no i can't you know in terms of whether
he was still
there at the hotel so i guess there is
something to be said that it should be
the innkeepers rights to uh
decide whether they really want to share
it and and
i know that you guys probably won't
agree with that but
a compelling you know because it could
be an awkward situation because you're
you're looking at the person's computer
you're saying i want you know how does
that part how does the land keeper have
a right but
we'll we'll discuss this
come come september we'll have this
conversation
well i think we know your position
you're you're you would be opposed
you're you're adamantly you would like
to see this bill die a quick death i
know i get that
so represent here
thank you um i i agree with the interim
study because i see there is a balance
here between
public safety and and the rights to
expect privacy
um and so i think in from study i think
we need to think carefully
where that line is between your
expectation of privacy when you rent
something versus concerned for
safety for for other folks safety so i
would agree with the interim
study right
okay
all right so uh representative mclean
i'll let you vote on this one since i
feel bad about the last one
okay um all those in favor of interim
study please raise your hand
no
okay
ten to zip all right and who made the
motion um
who who made that motion oh yeah
i guess
well let's see uh representative hunt
and secondly representative petrusek
i believe is what
i did
okay
well this is only this list is okay so
now i have
relative way to measure hunt him
johnson's able herbert fargo weston
and mcaleer
okay i move uh ought to pass
so representative johnson seconds by
motion
okay so hunt ham johnson abel herbert
fargo weston and mclaren
all those in favor say aye
those opposed
moved unanimously
okay
will's gone but
all right uh relative to consumer rights
regarding uh towing of vehicles who
would like to make the inexpedient
motion
representative
weston
and is that this one second by
representative ham
okay
any discussion on the motion of
inexpensive to legislate
okay all those in favor raise your hand
those opposed
you moved unanimously
and learned to zip
okay
uh
relative to privacy of online consumer
customer
that's information so
this bill
it seems like a lot of states are
playing with a lot of different ideas
with this and
my feeling is that we should interim
study it just just we want to we want to
pay attention to what's going on in
other states and see what's happening
my concern is that some states might be
passing it and no one actually
uses the statute that it just sits there
and and uh that
if you guys know me that that's an
anathema for the way i do business i i i
want to make sure we actually pass
something that solves the problem
the right of private action of people
trying to sue verizon or sue their
income that jim seems like a nightmare i
just don't know how
that is ever going to work the right
private action you know you really had
you got to have something that you could
give the at the attorney general
something to work with but yeah
representing if you if you enter and
study this do you have any idea which
direction you're going to go to make it
into a workable bill i my attitude would
be is just to collect information what's
going on all these different states
and the case laws of what's going on in
those states and seeing what what's
really happening but you don't have any
legislation i i really have no clue on
how to handle this i really don't
um
um i i don't do facebook
because i just there's no way i could
ever feel
safe with wasted facebook you know
just you know you never know who's there
who's connecting and you and then you
look at this you know they keep changing
the long list of things you can check in
and get in and out like oh my god this
is i thought your comment
that gentleman was here about yep you're
officially a nerd i mean he was just
talking over oh yeah he was definitely
talking about in terms of how
yeah yeah as someone of a nerd i guess
um the truth is if you really understand
the technology these broadband providers
they can't even they don't even access
your debt your data they're picking up
packets and moving them that's all
they're doing right they're the mailman
they're yeah yeah ask the mailman what's
in my in my mail
and
screen my mail is you know and there was
a good internet
supposedly right and the other concern i
had was enforcement and and i think the
attorney general's office had quite a
bit to say about this as well
and you know i if if nothing else i
think that whole piece of it needed to
be revisited that
um
and not that i want to pick a fight but
you remember for those of us have been
on this committee
we've had this issue several times and
we've struggled with it
you know and we struggle
right in this case it was right
and
and i in
my in my mind is let's let's be sure we
can you know
we really think what we're doing is
going to address
the problem
if that's the case then why don't we itl
it
yeah which is what we did to the last
version i agree
you want to just kill it no yeah you
guys how do you guys feel about just
killing it
i
i think this problem
is much bigger than these three pages
there's a real concern about our about
our information and
it is it is a commodity and people are
multi-multi-billionaires
just just just off of our information so
how do they get the information if we
don't volunteer it now when you sign up
for facebook or anything else you're
volunteering a lot of information
and then when you conduct commerce
online they have your information
and then of course we have data breaches
that we always hear about
you know years after it's been oh hey
somebody had the names of like
even
even department of defense and social
security have had data breaches uh and
so
um
excuse me uh
personal defense personal records uh
i don't know how
the internet service provider
uh how we can even regulate them in in
knowing whether or not they're
they are the ones now i believe they
certainly have the ability to track all
of your
uh all of your activity there's no
question that they have that capacity
they have right they could get it if
they wanted to whether or not they do or
don't
i'm sure they do
um but i just don't know how in the
world we could even begin to
uh
to regulate this yeah well you really
hit the nail on the head when you say is
even though
and and i remember talking to this guy
who when i
before we had fiber come to the house we
we actually had this guy did shortwave
you know and he said to me that known
certain terms said yes it is he is
capable for him to see
what's going back and forth
if it was un
unencrypted if it's encrypted he can't
see it but if it was unencrypted and and
let's face a lot of stuff we do we we
don't we don't pay attention to every
web page and see if it's encrypted
before we load it up so um
but he said you know there's
he would never do that because it just
has a business policy why would you ever
want to do that
but more importantly is
how would you be able to prove
that that data that that information it
was them who did it
that's the thing i mean it's how you're
gonna how are we gonna have to prove
who's the one who actually was the
league viewers are advancing so so
rapidly now with with quantum computing
uh that basically there will be no
encryption of anything because as soon
as you can encrypt it you can decrypt it
at the speed of light that's what
quantum quantum computing is all about
i'm studying this back within my
bachelor's degree
so
uh it's a real threat and it's really
starting to happen so so is it worth
interim study or just kill this bill and
let's wait let's wait the next session
to see what's going on
i have a minor in physics i still have
six more hours to get the degrees okay
it's way beyond my head yeah represent
him i i agree
i have a master's in business and this
is way beyond
me or us i think to come up with
something you know we can study it and
try to understand it but i don't know
what we're going to come up with
so i would be okay with itl it because i
don't know what we'd come up with okay
representative weston seconded by
representative ham moves in expedient to
legislate
any discussion on the motion
all those in favor raise your hand
those opposed
moves unanimously
okay last but not least
requiring warning labels and consumer
advertising containing
pfas
represent but i'm not going to make a
motion but i have been doing a lot of
research over the last
a couple months about
actually over the last four years about
pfas
this bill um i i do know that uh the
state of california and maine have
passed bills regarding pfas
one of them is labeling the other one is
the one in california is banning pfas in
juvenile products
so there's a lot of um
there are some states that
have been
um studying this and have moved forward
and the governors have signed bills
regarding pfas um
this bill really is not ready for prime
time that's for sure interim study you
know we're not studying warning labels i
think we're studying how to move forward
with educating
people on pfas and not only that the
sludge
now that's spread on farmlands
has contaminated many farms um that we
know in maine so there's a big problem
with pfas so i'm not sure if interim
study is the way to go with this bill um
we can certainly you know move forward
next year i'll be here next year well we
did pass one study committee already on
pfas right it's um uh bill boyd's yeah
boys right
right so so we can just roll that into
that's what i'm saying it really
includes that
so we could itl this one
yes chris
the thing that struck me
was the
dumping of
contaminated material
in new hampshire dumps
and and i you know i would be all about
saying you can't do that but
yeah i don't know
you just
i don't know but i mean if
it's against the law and somebody and
somebody measures it then they've broken
the law i mean i wasn't gonna do it no
no i don't know how to do it right but
to me that was for my yeah because i saw
the stuff here it's in everything you
know right so you don't know what's you
dump the dish you know the washing
machine you don't know that the rubber
ring had pfas in it yep right but
just as an observation uh the the
business about taking it from mass and
dumping it in manchester right that's
huge too is is to me uh something that i
i definitely would go after if we could
yeah solid waste is a big problem yes
representative yeah i'm i'm actually
encouraged by the education that's going
on about this issue and a couple of
um originators of pfas up north have
changed their tune and one is ski wax
you cannot find fluoridated ski wax
anymore
and the second is car washes
the local i work with a guy up in the
canon advisory commission whose business
is car wash and they're getting away
from putting pfas in the wax that you
use simoniz hot wax doesn't have it
because the word is getting out to stop
it at the source and i really think
that's where we have to put our energies
but i like the idea of the study
committee because that'll just keep the
questions well we have that study
committee already we already had that
study committee already what bill boyd's
uh bill is
interim study okay
yeah we kept we kept that so we have
something to keep the conversation
but it's interesting about the wax
because when um we bought our new volvo
uh they sold us on this um glycol
there's some surface they put over it
that's supposed to mean that we don't
need the wax so they were supposed to
say no act but i had at the time i said
i wonder if it's got pretty fast is that
what they're doing putting a p-pass coat
over the
car or not
i will say our car is taking it's it's
it's amazing how well
it's taking the the you know you know it
runs better when it's got a good coat
you have to worry about that right i
don't know my daughter upgraded her
prius and she's got this flashy red lead
you know it just
it just looks fast just looking at it
so just another comment about chemicals
and bpas
years ago
there was you know study commissions
committees uh and now bpa is banned in
you know most products in the united
states you can't add people that's where
the water or the kids baby
the baby bottle issue came out right so
we did regulate that so there is you
know precedent um and so
yeah we can kill this because we have an
interim study i'd love to be on the
study committee
right we have an internship well it's
not a study committee we have we have we
have his as an interim study so that we
can we can free to think about any and
take it anywhere we want to go with it
so we can we can meet in the in the fall
that would meet in the fall i'll work on
this yep okay i'd like to bring you know
i'll do a lot of research and
um with the other bills that have passed
in other states and i think we really
need to do something about it
it's it's definitely up and coming um so
but we can kill this one we can kill
this one if everybody's okay with that
representative
yes thank you
we do have that other study committee
and in my mind this seems to be more of
an environmental
scientific
focus
versus commerce focus
as to what should have labels and
what the um
hazards are and so forth so congress i
think it should be studied by
scientists and environmentalists
well it's funny you say that because um
we had an issue years ago the the bovine
growth hormone
and
they used to send it to the ag committee
and the agriculture committee they just
struggled over they just didn't know how
to handle it they didn't it was it was
at the end of the day you know they'd
often it would come to the floor with a
split vote you know that they couldn't
make up a decision they couldn't and
and uh finally they sent the bill to
commerce
and
and and commerce said no this is this is
uh you know an issue that absolutely
if uh
to take it completely opposite rather
than telling you whether you had you
know that the terms of the grove home
they actually started using as a
marketing tool
to say no we don't
have
so we didn't need to do it so sometimes
the reason you send it to to commerce is
because we don't get too bogged down on
the science that we talk about what is
really going on in the marketplace and
what is the right you know how how the
market is going to handle a product and
and i've always said you know that uh
you know what what is wrong with a
business just saying you know and where
with a private
honor if they want if they think they
think bovine grown hormones a good thing
then let them advertise that or
vice versa if they think it's a bad
thing then they could should be able to
advertise it without without having the
state intervening
so
okay
uh
who would like to make the motion
okay
yeah you're not on the committee but
yeah right
all right okay representative mclear
so um
chris we'll go over these
you know before we take them up on on
the exact we'll go over and talk about
which ones people want to okay
and so anybody who wants to you take it
for the full committee just make sure
you let your leader
know
if you want to take it
okay uh representative macular seconded
by uh
representative ham
moves
i-t-l
american
mclear
mackinham
[Laughter]
i can learn him
okay all those in favor of the motion
say aye
those opposed
so moved unanimously
all right
we did it
and look at that
jonathan you thought that was a big list
that we were going to be here all
morning right can i ask you a question a
question for you
i noticed that next week wednesday's
schedule includes all
i did i did and i will i will see if i
could uh intervene now and see if i can
change it
um
but we do i do know we have 1503
is still there so we will have to meet
no matter what for the tina three the
problem is this um i have to close the
calendar and wednesday at noon
and i'm my goal just to be so you all
know is my goal is for us to be done
next week on thursday but we can't meet
in just one day yeah because anyways
thursday morning so we don't have to
come both days i mean to come here and
bill seems
well we still have the afternoon bill
well i
let me find out whether i can cancel
subcommittees and move things around and
then just have everything come on
thursday
you would rather just do this one day
well yeah to drive that far to talk
about one bill to me it seems
well it wouldn't be just one bill we
you know in terms of uh
in terms of wednesday if we were really
able to get everything done
my boy i'd be well i don't know i don't
know i think they close i know i know
they
officially the calendar doesn't come out
until tonight but you know how much i
can cook and cook it let me see what i
can do but
i
i think we can announce we can actually
just announce the subcommittees are not
meeting
okay but it would be really good if it
were just one day for everybody i will
uh
aim that because we did so well and
assuming we're going to do just this
well this afternoon
let's assume that we'll that anything
that's still hanging out there will be
done thursday morning okay
i think that would be good and i think
you know even if we start at nine
o'clock it means a full day but it's
only one full day i i hear you
you come a long ways too
uh
okay everybody everybody likes the one
day okay all right
[Laughter]
but my goal is that we would be done
that day
uh you know next thursday we would exec
everything on on you know so that means
you have to stay here no matter how late
or how bad the snow storm is
that a week from now
so
all right so i'll go on
you guys want to go to lunch yeah okay
good
is
they really should protect them
oh
and she was so busy
do you want to be in on a we get out of
caucus yeah before we okay so um i will
do a caucus
monday or tuesday one day which day you
like better
probably monday okay but i can work
around let me grab joyce
because i don't have to drive far
connie you're not here you're here this
afternoon yeah
yeah the liquor bills
is um
okay
that's exactly what's happening
i'm bringing it
oh
but i'm just
thank you very much
oh yeah
hey
um
uh
are you
going downstairs
where
there's a red arrow here
anyway
is
i don't think i um
my dog this morning
uh
then
okay
i'll get it
okay so um
the two other amendments they're
they were sent to me unbeknownst to me
because i don't check my emails
so there uh hopefully we will get those
so let's just take the one we got in
hand and get this one out of the way so
that is hp 1039.
okay
okay so uh hp 1039 uh started out with
my original bill that i put in for the
liquor commission
related to
clarifying that a beverage
manufacturer
if they want to have this uh off-premise
location
that they don't have to actually
manufacture
at that location
which was generally thought to what the
bill was to be but it didn't really
state it clearly
and uh but that it was modeled if you
all remember we
we've modeled after what we did with the
wine
bill madame labelle's bill which was for
her to have an outside location which
was clearly trying to make wine in a
shopping mall was probably not a good
idea
and so
so this will allow them to have a
separate location and it clarifies it we
did get an ag's opinion that what we
wrote did say that but this clarifies it
once and for all
uh in the hearing i then brought in two
more issues that uh the liquor
commission had come to them
and as you'll remember they've been
audited
and been thoroughly
reviewed in multiple cases and so two
other issues that came up
well
the one main issue was the the idea of
someone actually taking a license for
multiple years
in which nobody's ever thought that that
was a good idea
and never been used but
evidently i was around when we passed
that
but maybe
maybe that was the year i was i was not
on the committee did we figure that was
maybe the year i wasn't on the committee
that year
yeah
well i thought i probably thought it was
a good idea it was a good business thing
that they didn't why you have to fill
out a form every year why not do it
every other year but so anyway so uh the
auditor said if no one's ever done it
you know get it off out of the statute
so that's what section three
is is to remove that then section two is
um
you know this is the devil's in the
details when you write laws
and
that um this is someone who's a a direct
shipper who
the commission becomes attention to
somebody who's shipping into the state
and but the person never filed with the
state and paid us their eight percent
the john hunt memorial eight percent tax
and instead um they just waited and then
the commission points it out well you
lost your license and they just waited
90 days and then they started up again
so this is to ensure that when they lose
their license they really lose their
license
john hunt's rule of licensure
so
any questions on the amendment
or the underlying bill so there's
another one is it did i just send it to
you
yeah i'm sorry no problem no it was it
was
right there
farmer's market
and that one
mr chair are you getting any of these
electronically could we
i know
can we send them to the whole committee
i know i i know you can't group it
i know you can't group it on your phone
but i've
represented weston's watching
kristen maybe you could send it to bruh
to the committee that yeah
oh oh okay got it
any discussion on 1039
yes thank you i just want to understand
the multi-year licenses and why that's
being repealed
nobody ever used it okay gotcha thank
you
nice idea but you know i just didn't
know why it was but thank you yeah it
was a nice idea but nobody ever ever
took advantage of it
but
okay
so what do i have for names on this
committee all right
i've got hunt polio van houten patuck
abramson abramson okay so greason is
is that right okay yeah so hunt patoos
that greece is going to replace max and
van houten and bilio
all right i'm sorry and what i'm i'm
jane
okay yeah okay got it
how do i pronounce it correctly
julio
and he ran for governor
i guess nobody pronounced it right right
that's like you know even in my family
they pronounce it
right well it's like you know here we
thought it was key like you know we can
alone the russian language probably has
a whole another
okay
all right so uh
representative hunt
second by
representative patusek
okay uh to pass on the amendment
and amendment number
o
okay all those in favor of the amendment
please raise your hand
one two three four five
okay ought to pass as amended
the representative hunt for two sec
and discussion saying none all those in
favor raise your hand one two three four
five
okay
all right
well i i'm waiting we're waiting for
these amendments here
right so i've got now i
have all right so i have
1583 now
okay
okay so 1583 had several parts the first
two were related to
locations of liquor stores
trying to enforce that as a nightmare
so
the amendment takes that out
and
the third section
of the bill
was their hours of operation
and the question was to remove easter
because easter is
not a high holiday this is something
close to a holiday
but then when i sat down with the liquor
commissioner and we were discussing this
and reading the paragraph that says
uh it's already the commission may in
its discretion
so well if it's got discretion then why
tell them any days let them
them decide and operate and
what days they want so we're moving
any particular day so we're not
offending anybody religiously
except maybe
somebody cares about thanksgiving day
but probably the native americans are
probably happy to see us take that out
too
so
any
discussions on the amendment
kate do you want you want a copy or
just
okay
any comments
kate do you want to tell us how terrible
this is
how bad this is
so it could be potentially that we could
actually have a liquor store open on
thanksgiving and christmas
but that only would be if the liquor
commission thought that was a good idea
you know santa claus needs a place to
stop when he comes to new hampshire
all right seeing uh
no discussion
all right uh the
representative
patusek mr chairman i just want to say
that i just think it particularly
targets christians
no that's okay we took it out and so it
doesn't target anybody the problem was
the problem was that we were
theoretically open on passover well it's
but not on easter it says it may open
for business on any sunday or legal
holiday you don't even need that
sentence in there now
i'm saying this is specifically
targeting
those who practice a christian faith
that's all right
i thought i was going the opposite
direction
by taking out any identifying qualities
okay that you're entitled to your
opinion
you actually don't even you actually
don't even need this section alone you
repeal the whole section of the law
um
i think
i i wouldn't be surprised that the the
unions
might want to see this paragraph okay
okay
uh all those uh in favor of the
amendment please raise your hand
one two
three four
all those opposed
it's fine
okay this is happening amendment
okay
all right representative patusek
seconded by representative hunt
moves out to pass as amended all those
in favor raise your hand
one two three four five
zero okay
great
okay
all right so we have uh 16 13 now
all right
and
1613 was a very long extensive bill
and open up
lots of different subjects about how we
want to
treat farmers with uh when it comes to
liquor but
at the end of the day
the
fundamental issue as i saw it
is that um
how much a
farmer has to pay the state of new
hampshire
for a license
and so instead of paying
ninety 1692 dollars a year
that they would be able to get a license
for three hundred bucks
any questions
and
the liquor commission is here smiling so
he must be happy
yeah why don't you sit here and and so
so that everybody can hear you loud and
clear
and you have to push the
button there you go perfect thank you mr
chairman
um for the record my name is aiden moore
i'm the legal coordinator for the state
liquor commission and i just wanted to
uh on your comments mr chairman that
this uh amendment would not be limited
to just farmers right this would be for
any business person who decides they
want to open a
a
a starter a nano store
you're going to go there
i didn't use the word i know you didn't
so that
it has broad implications
yes it definitely it definitely opens up
more opportunity for people to be in the
business but at the end of the day still
they still got to get a federal license
which is going to be
much more of a bear than our state
license
so
did you um
have to pull the mic did you draft this
amendment yes i did with the liquor
commission yes i did okay
thanks
but did you just say it's going to open
up a can of worms
no no no no no the the the canned worms
i mean when you're when you get a
federal license right they have
huge requirements and you know
so
the
the fact that we have a state license is
pretty
limited in terms of what we do but it's
not
but in this case that that
we we've taken obviously we just saved
them thirteen hundred dollars
to get in terms of getting a license so
so this
no i'm confused this is
this is
oh
okay
yes representative greeson question uh
in the original bill it has the section
one that talks about 65 percent of the
final products will be
from products grown in new hampshire
what happens to that all of that is gone
okay so if you look if you look at the
amendment
uh and this is always
always good things to learn
is that it starts out on line five it
says amend the bill by replacing all
after the enacting clause that basically
means everything that was in the
original bill i i got that but then
you've got
so then what happened so one and two so
one
so then for them to find the
rsa
that we're amending
they're saying in section and so one
that little one there means section one
of the bill
new paragraph
so they're saying that
in rsa 178.6 if you go find paragraph
three
you're gonna now add a new paragraph
three a
okay
and then in that three a because this
was creating is the actual creating that
they could there's somebody under a
thousand and then
section two of the bill says now let's
go to rsa 178 29
roman numeral five little b
and in this section
we're going to identify the dollar
amounts
that those licensures are are
okay everybody got it
all right um
representative hunt
between
yep
all those in favor please say aye
those opposed
so move unanimously
uh motion
by
patusek
hunt
all those in favor of the bill as
amended say aye
those opposed
five zip
code
sorry we didn't give you a good in
everything you wanted but you know i
think i think this is a huge step
and we thank you for bringing this to
our attention
yes
usually when it gets to um well actually
it's not it's now going to be says uh
it'll be relative to certain liquor
manufacturers
so it will not say farmers anymore
okay
okay 15.56
all right
and we have the amendment
which ones this is yeah we
already did 15 57
january 25th
oh yeah okay
yes
all right so 1556.
um
i believe i forwarded it to everybody
was the bulletin but i'm not sure did
did you guys get the bulletin
it was it was a bulletin
uh
is that that a bill or is a bullet
yeah oh shhh
okay so what this uh to remind everybody
with this bill this bill was the one in
which
um
it became to our attention that if you
had
multiple
liquor licenses
that the commission may require you
to have to use separate registers
to
use the different purchases so if you
came if you were
a beverage manufacturer and also had a
restaurant you're in the restaurant you
had a nice meal and say now can i take a
six-pack home
they might be apt to send you to a
different cash register to get that
six-pack
so with this
bulletin makes it clear
is that that will not be necessary that
as long as their point of sale software
is able to handle those multiple
transactions so that they can um
the licensee can appropriately
give the commission uh exactly uh what
sales of that category that license
information
that there would be no need to have a
separate point of sale system
so at this point
um
i think i mean i don't i don't want to
kill the bill only because i would like
to hold on to it so we can actually see
come and come back in september and hear
hear everything yes so i can ask and yes
what's
up this is amendment here
the licensee who offers
in the site may use the same point of
sale as liquor license so would the
bulletin handle this aiden
why don't you come over to the
microphone please
thank you sir
my understanding from the example if i
recall the example correctly is a
a business that holds a what we call a
combination license beer and wine
license
has
a within their facility
a
separate food operation that that right
prepares food to go or operates a food
store
then
that they needed to have two registers
and i am here to tell you that that is
not correct
that the only licensee
that excuse me the only transactions
that needed to be recorded for the
purposes
of alcohol one registry will do it if if
i decide i want to get a milk
six pack of beer and go get myself a
meatball sub
from the from the food side of the house
there's no need to have that done
through a separate register we
that's just not accurate
okay
so it's not it's not in the guidance
document
because
it's it's not
accurate it's not required right
so hence the reason why i'd like to
interim study this pill
so that we will have a chance to come in
september just to make sure
we if anybody hears of a horror story
where they had to use separate
point-of-sale systems well i would i
would also point out to the chairman and
the committee members that
we
always encourage
businesses who have questions
to contact the commission if you're not
sure
or if you're relying upon information
that's provided to you by someone else
you can get the
answer to your question from the
commission
and and we'll be happy to answer that
for you and
unfortunately over my time
there are a lot of
business people who sometimes will rely
upon
comments offered to them by someone else
saying well you can't do that because i
was told you can't do that 20 years ago
and so you
and and it's not accurate so we would
strongly encourage
any business owner who holds a license
from the commission if they have
questions
contact us we want to make sure
you get clarity
in the in the questions that you have to
ask yeah i would say that there is
two is two issues here one is that
absolutely there are times where people
are rely on old news old information
and or let's just say wise tale you know
i always thought that was true
but they're also the other problem with
this is when
a
auditor comes in
and
the the person the licensee starts
trying to produce the reports
and the auditor says you don't have this
on a separate point of sale system
and kind of grouchy you know
i have to you know spend a little more
time here sorting through your numbers
or something that the uh
and this would only be an audit because
most of the time
the licensee just fills out the form and
mails it in
so this would be an audit and it
sometimes is a little scary to have
an auditor there
and and they seem a little rough and
gruff that the licensee might be fearful
to
say can i talk to your boss and see
whether you really
have to have it done separately i'll
make sure the examiner
named amy knows that she's being
portrayed as a rough
scary person
that she needs to say in a friendly
happy boys i'm so glad to see that you
have your information
as as readily available as you do
but to to
to address mr thompson's question and
the industry circular that was produced
yes in relation to 1556
was to clarify
the issue that was presented
at a beverage manufacturers facility
so that it's it's written in that
vein alone
we did not address this question that mr
thompson mentioned
because
it's it's not an issue as far as
as far as you're concerned but that but
maybe for the licensee
that when it came time
for amy to
that maybe they felt well amy wouldn't
be the person who
would visit the
retailer okay
so
um who who's that who's what order is
that
there is no auditor that visited
i mean they don't visit that's not their
the auditors
really work with manufacturers and
wholesalers
because those are the businesses that
have tax liability
right and they're there to ensure that
the records match up with the reports i
would think it would always come in with
someone who's also um
does rooms and meals
well it may
if this if this was attributed it would
probably to be an investigator someone
from the enforcement side of the house
but
you know i just want to make
sure that it's crystal clear to you all
that the requirement for a second
register under that example is not
necessary
got it
so my question then mr chair is why do
we want to put this off
why not just post the amendment
well there is no amendment for this one
what
okay we just were given them and we had
the amendment in our in our file for
1556.
0.282
but that's the old
that was the old amendment right what's
the date on that
january 25th yeah
right so we don't want to say we don't
want it it's that's not necessary
okay well
okay so then why
so i just want to i just want to interim
study 1556 period
okay and then and that way we can
be you know if anybody has a problem
we'll hear about it
come september or by september
so
all right everybody comfortable with the
motion of interim study
no amendment that amendment that
amendment came in during the hearing and
it was just
thinking that it was out of the problem
but it really
was no problem
but
okay
all right through all those in favor of
interim studying
1556 raise your hand
one two three four five zero okay
okay
all right
what do we got next
okay
okay good to see you again
i guess we gotta take five until they
they get receded
fargo says she stays on liquor because
it's fun
it is insurance is boring
the business
okay so we got uh hunt bartlett greason
terry is here
hey
okay
take your conversations today are we all
set over here
okay
1559 representative hunt
seconded by representative bartlett
moves out to pass on 1559 is there any
discussion on the question
so you
you're still
you i gave you all the like ones going
to have
johnson sit down for a key
because you're you're already here so
yeah so you're
you're you're you're in your case
okay
you all right
you look late
yeah okay
okay
the question is not to pass on the bill
represent hunt
second by representative bartlett
you're advising you were a co-sponsor
weren't you
[Music]
you're the prime sponsor this one okay
yes she is
okay
any discussion on the motion of
uh to pass
seeing none
all those in favor raise your hand
two three four
six seven okay
i have was i have hunt
bartlett oh you're not on this no i'm uh
i'm i'm
no well i just i just appointed johnson
ammon oh okay
[Laughter]
one two three four five six
i have six
yeah see this is something got screwy
with when we move people around here
somebody somebody's supposed to come
should be somebody else's on this list
so
we still have the senate bill so
so we'll see what happens there
okay uh next up is house bill 1558
relative insurance holding companies
okay
a hunt seconded by representative
bartlett
moves ought to pass
any discussion on the motion about to
pass
all those in favor please say aye
those opposed
soon moved unanimously
okay
1019 establishing committee decided to
replace them with certain professional
licenses with mandatory minimum
liability insurance requirements
oh my god
representative bartlett i'd make a
motion to um itl rtl
one second by hunt
you want to speak to your motion
um
sure
there's really no
enforcement licenses are
are necessary liability is not going to
make up the difference
for a license
that's probably adequate
it was a nice idea but it was not never
going to work
so any other discussion
anybody want to speak speak to this
speak nowhere forever more hold your
peace
okay
motion is inexpensive to legislate all
those in favor place your hand
okay
fix up
do you want me to write the blurb oh no
i'll i'll
let's see i made the motion
we'll worry about exactly next time
okay relative minimum
non-forfeiture amounts under the
standard non-forfeiture law for
individual deferred annuities
if you know what this means
okay
represent bartlett second by
representative hunt
tell us what this bill's about
chris
oh i'm sorry um i
just got to it i know okay um this is
requested by the insurance department
um let's see naic requested to reduce
the
to the amount of interest and we had um
attorney silverstein explain to us that
this
you know was just necessary and it was
it was a minimalist amount
so that we
helped make them we didn't have to get
turned over to abandoned property
somebody wants an annuity
you always get excited when you look and
see something's on the abandoned
property then you find it
it's a fraction of a dollar
okay
jerry just walked out of the room
you just walked out oh
okay
and
okay all those in favor raise your hand
one two
three four five
we're good
okay
why
i
i am
on thursdays i have sewing lessons for
my 10 year old granddaughter
i'm going to be really early
you're doing my great
you know it was funny because i was
looking at all the bills that we had not
done the subcommittee
and putting this together i said oh my
god how are we going to get through all
these bills and then i looked at the
insurance ones and i thought oh we're
just going to speed right through these
so that then it's when i scheduled the
liquor
to be in front because i knew we had a
bunch of amendments for them
so
you would think i've done this before
all right
repealing the granite state paid family
leave program
all right
okay
so
representative johnson's in for
kate
okay
all right
okay johnson hunt
interim study
and you want to speak your emotion or
yeah so um
talking with the sponsor
and co-sponsors on this bill
they also have another bill very similar
to this in labor
so it's almost redundant so they're
going to work with that one and we'll
hold this one off for right now
okay
all good
all right all those in favor of interim
study raise your hand
one two three four five
we're done
you